so first of all congratulations i feel
like you're kind of everywhere right now
how is life right now
life's good i actually just got back to
new york last night i was in there i was
in scotland i was in my family
and by yeah coming back to the
invitation and press for that it comes
out tomorrow which is really exciting
and it's kind of like my first big
cinema movie so i'm really excited to go
and get popcorn and
bye i think it's
good how excited are you or are you
feeling nervous i mean obviously when
you're leading your first film like this
there's a there's a lot going on a lot
of emotions
yeah i mean they're obviously conscious
that you want people to like it and
enjoy it and stuff but
no i mean it's more exciting did a lot
of hard work on it i came in quite last
minute so i was really thrown into the
deep end but
working with jessica was just
unbelievable and truly the best director
an actor could ever ask for i'm working
with natalie as well
she's magic she's just such a sweet
human she's so talented
and
so yeah i mean whatever happens
past
we all did our best and we loved filming
so i mean
yeah
no you are fantastic in this is this
your first thriller
this is my first thriller yeah
psychological thriller yeah it was
really cool because
it was my first opportunity i love like
playing characters i love
being a character actor i just think
it's really
there's a lot more fun to do and this
character as well it's almost like i
played two characters at the same time
um so yeah this is my first
psychological
thriller horror thing uh so yeah
hopefully i get to do another one
yeah what did you think did you like the
film have you seen that i love the film
so i'm a huge fan of thrillers i'm a
huge fan of horror um any time a movie
focuses on somebody getting invited to
this beautiful home and and mayhem kind
of ensues right up my alley how would
you handle being in this house how would
you handle being invited to a house like
this well i actually hate horror films
they scare me i don't understand how you
can say it
and like just be scared like i can do
this just plug my ears
i do that as well but i do i do one ear
like that and then kind of like close my
eyes a little bit so it doesn't look
like i mean obviously
yeah i just don't really they just scare
me i don't want to be scared
to be scared
and what what was it about kind of this
story and this character you kind of
already alluded to it a little bit kind
of you're playing two different
characters but what do you love about
this story uh i think i mean i don't
want to give too much away honestly but
i think i just love the perspective that
it came from
um and i was from
the classic story
uh is from a female perspective
and
how
you kind of follow her journey and to
her ultimate
and i can't say i don't want to ruin the
film
but yeah i loved i loved the take on
that i thought that was really cool and
and really important and
very nice i think
i love that
you know i know you just hung out with
your family who in your life are you
most excited to show a new project that
you've done
um
yeah i'd probably say my sister
my girlfriend
uh as well my agents back in the uk
olympia bell
because i started off years and years
ago with them so it's really cool to see
us like travel together like on this
journey together
obviously my manager just honestly just
everyone in my life like it's really
special to
do all this work and then they get to
see it and
regardless of how good or bad it is lie
to you and tell you it was amazing
listen i don't even lie to you it's
great um shooting gossip girl shooting
the invitation
two different kind of genres how
different was the experience obviously
going from tv and a film
yeah well i mean honestly the genre was
different but the biggest the biggest
difference was
i mean shooting in new york and shooting
in budapest and hungry that was a big
difference but just the way that their
film tv is like a lot quicker
a lot of the time you don't get the
script so it's hard to like
create a character
kind of journey prior to filming whereas
films it's a lot slower and i actually
really love doing film
and it's definitely more of a
kind of
you really throw yourself into it and
you've been kind of definitely becoming
really immersed in this world filming
was shorter so
yeah different working with different
people older cast
comparative to gossip girl where
everyone's a little bit younger so yeah
it was really cool love them both
equally but just in different ways
that's awesome
what is it about gossip girl that people
love so much i mean obviously the
original series the reboot like people
love it
yeah you know what i don't know i was in
i was in georgia and i got hit
i was filming some something out there
and
it came on and it got me and i
didn't know why but
i think it's i think people love new
york
i think this
it's very it's kind of like escapism
people love to just
indulge in
this ridiculousness of
wealth and parties and restaurants and
stuff and it's very clean it's very
aesthetically clever
and yeah i think it's all those things
and then everyone loves drama
you know everyone loves drama so
so much drama anything that you can
teach us anything you can tease us about
the new season
no
[Laughter]
i mean yeah it's still i think it's
definitely it's bigger so it's almost
like there's a bigger budget in it and i
don't know if that's true but it
definitely feels that way it feels more
expensive and there's definitely that
continuation of all these relationships
and
romances and heartbreaks and everything
you can expect i guess
anything you can tease about your
character do you have a say at all and
and where kind of the trajectory of the
the character from max is going to go
uh not for saying no i mean josh is
crazy
actually no that's yeah he will
josh saffron it says baby and he
definitely is open and he lets you kind
of like
suggest things and he'll ask you and
he'll want to by you and
and that's really really cool as well
but i mean you do you want to trust them
with their craft and what they do and
have the same in return
yeah
such a huge popularity surrounding the
descendant films as you know
um
was that tricky at all kind of breaking
that disney mold
yeah
kinda i mean even when i got the job i
was definitely i knew it
wasn't what i wanted to do it was
fantastic it was amazing really really
good fun
but i i didn't ever wanted to be like a
disney
person so i was already kind of looking
beyond and passed to
how to not be associated
i mean it's hard because
americans love disney they do
they do indeed but yeah i know it was uh
it was an amazing time in my life for
sure and such an amazing opportunity
working with kenny ortega and the cast
and stuff was really cool so
um
yeah i have an amazing team
i got surrounded by fantastic people
with great vision and stuff so yeah
keep fighting the good fight martin
it's good uh can we talk about your
fashion
you can indeed i'm wearing it right now
got some dr
oh i like it
ambassador very important uh you're a
met gala i'm still not over it are you
over it
i'm not i i wake up but that's the first
thing i think of it
yeah i know and that was that was
incredible i mean not only can it go
into the net but going with vr
and having kim jones dress me in
something that he designed and someone
that asked me oh what material do you
want here what fabrics what colors and
stuff
so yeah it was it was very very surreal
experience
do you feel like it looked amazing it
looked good it was on theme i didn't
realize how big a thing that people
going on theme was people were like yeah
referring to titanic
yeah you love a little bit of jack from
the titanic
was that on purpose
no no i just i just like playing that i
leave it and i love that but yeah i
didn't realize how big people were like
on like
keeping the theme
you kind of think because when someone
doesn't they're like
what's good
it's true it's kind of a lot of pressure
to like fit and especially on a night
like that on that kind of red carpet i
feel like in fashion especially when it
comes to men's fashion there's a lot
more
i guess the word is people are really
outside of the box like we're seeing
oscar isaac you know with the skirt and
brad pitt with the skirt what are you
feeling about how kind of the the lines
are being blurred when it comes to men's
uh fashion especially my carpets
um
honestly i don't have
that big of opinion on it i think it's
really cool i think why not you know
2022 and
just to kind of
challenge all these
patriarchal conditions that we all have
inside us and
i mean
no harm don't fail you know this isn't
why not have fun be expressive i think
especially in this industry people get
so caught up in
a lot of the politics and stuff and so i
think this is a place in the world where
people can look and
and be inspired and feel liberated and
feel
all these things yeah
i love that all right so you might see
me in a dress one day
i was back well that's actually what i
just wanted to know i think you would
rock it look awesome on you
well we wear kilts in scotland so it's
kind of like a dress a skirt yeah and
morgan paul you should see me in one
do you have a photo of it on your
instagram i want to see this now
i don't i mean i'll post one on my story
it'll just be free so you can see
do it so when you see it
that's for me that was for me unique i
love it okay so just wrapping things up
you're just such a good actor you know
there's so many exciting things coming
up for you
so much to be you know happy for right
now what is your dream role
um i honestly kind of just take it
as it comes but try not save myself
to big um
expectations but in saying that i really
want to be a bond villain
oh
oh i can see that i know you can see
that i was always james bond but then i
was definitely starting to sway toward
the villain i think it'd be so fun
you want to be the villain
yeah bond villain i mean if they offered
me james bond i'm not going to say no
but
yeah i think a bond would be so fun and
the big shoes to fill with some of the
icons that i've gone before but
yeah it would be exciting today do you
have a favorite james bond
or a favorite villain
uh i'm gonna have to say sean connery
i understand it's gonna be shot and
javier bardem
was amazing
old man he'll keep you up in there the
hair alone will keep me up at night
alone
uh hey was so nice talking to you
youtube
hopefully speak to you again and thank
you for all your love and support
you